[Музика]
Привіт, мене звати Наталія Супа, і тепер
настав час для нашого уроку англійської мови, я сподіваюся,
що ви залишайтеся вдома, будьте здорові та
щасливі, тому що ми багато займалися спортом
разом, і сьогодні ми говоримо про
смачну їжу  наша тема сьогодні про те, що буде
добре жити добре
вони кажуть мужність, що ти те, що
ти їси, що ти думаєш, що це
означає для тебе, чи означає це, що якщо ти
їси яблуко, ти схожий на яблуко або якщо ти
любиш картоплю, ти схожий на картоплю  ні, але
подивіться на цю картину, це
картина Хосе Ебера Арчібальда, це
італійський художник, який створив портрети
з їжі, він використовував їжу, щоб зробити
фотографії, щоб зробити портрети,
це виглядає дуже смішно, ми попрацюємо з нею
пізніше, але що ви  подумай над цією
фразою ти те, що ти їси, що це
означає
для мене, це означає, що якщо ти добре їсиш, якщо
ти їсиш здорову їжу, ти почуваєшся добре,
ти здоровий, тому я знаю, що ти
вже накакав тірамісу, тому ти знаєш, що
це таке  італійський десерт і
ти йо  Ви використовували для цього для приготування
ladyfingers печиво
кава яйця цукор сир маскарпоне
трохи какао какао-порошок, тому це
домашній тірамісу, то що це означає, що це
означає, що ви приготували його вдома, ви
не робили, ви не купили, тому його не
купили  в магазині, але є інший
тірамісу, готовий готовий, це
тірамісу приготований або готовий до приготування, коли
ви його купуєте,
тому це також італійський десерт, але що
щодо інгредієнтів, ми не впевнені, і
це питання, що корисніше
домашнього приготування  тірамісу або готовий тірамісу
добре, ми дізнаємося це зараз на уроці,
тому перед тим, як почати готувати, що нам
потрібно, нам знадобляться продукти, тому давайте
розглянемо продукти, які ви знаєте, подивіться на
цю картинку, можливо, ви знаєте, і я впевнений, що
ви  ви вже знаєте багато з них,
але давайте назвемо їх добре, добре, тому я сформулю
це так і повторю за мною
полуниця полуниця добре далі
боби квасоля зелена квасоля добре
це те, що це горіхи різні
види горіхів наступне так, це риба
не  xt одне яйця їм що це
так м'ясо апельсиновий сік лимон диня молочний
коктейль так що це це курка і
це газована або безалкогольний напій або газований напій
зверніть увагу на ці два слова лимон
диня його анаграма його анаграма це коли
ми можемо змінити
старі літери  і це буде ще одна бородавка,
лимонна диня, добре, тому ми маємо всі ці
продукти на дошці, і я хотів би,
щоб ви відповіли на це питання, як часто ви
їсте чи п'єте цю їжу як часто ви
п'єте, наприклад,
газовані напої, як на мене я ніколи  пити
газовані напої пити пити it's this it's
як дієслово та іменник те саме слово we te
not be drink так часто говорить Честер
рідко читає Co і ніколи Ніколас так що
для мене я часто п'ю каву та їм горіхи
я рідко їм м'ясо та рибу та я  ніколи не
пий газований напій або припой, і я ніколи не
їм гамбургер. Мені це не подобається добре подумай
про свою їжу, як часто ти п’єш
або їсиш якусь їжу, подумай про це і
вимовляй це добре, тому наступне завдання
ще раз переглянь ці продукти та цей
продукт  можна розділити на різні
групи, тому що існує багато різних
груп продуктів, тому давайте розмістимо їх у
правильній групі. Я намалю
вашу назву груп і дам вам
трохи часу, щоб розділити їх, яку групу
продуктів ми знаємо спочатку
вже бачив це напої Napoli напої
добре, тоді ми будемо їсти м'ясо
так так не морепродукти морепродукти так
морепродукти морепродукти це риба або різні
види морепродуктів в мурській мускус продуктивний
що звичайно фрукти та
овочі добре звичайно
що це десерти улюблені  одне
і чого ще нам тут не вистачає,
можливо молочні продукти так
молочний продукт його молочний сир і всі види продуктів
з молочного йогурту, а також у нас є так
зерна зерна зерна його продукти
з зернового хліба макарони піца та інші,
тому це група  продукти, і я
даю вам трохи часу, щоб довести весь цей
продукт у відповідній групі, тож я
даю вам дві хвилини, все добре
[Музика]
добре, тож давайте перевіримо, що ви  Ви зробили,
я покажу вам свій варіант, і ми зможемо
перевірити напої ми додаємо безалкогольний
напій кави або газований напій лимонад молочний молочний
коктейль так, це також напій, але це також
може бути десерт або прямі продукти
молочний коктейль
апельсиновий сік чай вода чудово  м'ясо що
ми сюди кладемо курку звичайно
м'ясо курки і булгур але булгур це дуже
повний спокій це комплекс це не
просто м'ясо, тому що
нам потрібно для булгуру що нам потрібно що нам потрібно для буті
нам потрібен хліб нам потрібен помідор так  і нам
потрібне м'ясо, тому це не
зовсім справжні овочі, добре, але є квасоля
салат помідор чудовий фрукт фрукти яблуко
банан виноград лимон диня диня та
полуниця десерт морозиво
печиво торт молочний коктейль сам цукор
морепродукти у нас є риба тільки молочні продукти у
нас є масло сир  молочний молочний коктейль,
йогурт і зерно, у нас тут хліб
чіпси піца і Ройс, у нас є
такі продукти, це допомагає нам, коли ми йдемо
в супермаркет, щоб знайти продукт, який нам
потрібен для приготування
їжі  o у нас є продукти, які ми можемо порахувати, або ми
не можемо порахувати, тому іменники, які ми можемо порахувати,
ми називаємо злічуваними, іменники, які ми
не можемо порахувати, називають незліченними.
Іменники, які можна порахувати, мають форму однини та
множини, а незліченні іменники не
мають цих форм, тому ми можемо  порахувати банани
один банан два банани так
лимонні ягоди або яйця ми можемо порахувати їх,
але ми не можемо порахувати м'ясо так ми не можемо
порахувати молоко ми не можемо порахувати сир це так
само як одне явище, як сир,
який і ми не можемо порахувати пізніше, я
вам покажу  як ми можемо порахувати ці
незліченні речі, але зараз пам'ятайте,
що ці іменники незліченні, то
чому нам це потрібно знати, ми побачимо
пізніше, але тепер для вас є завдання,
будь ласка, помістіть усі ці назви продуктів
у ці два стовпці: зліченні та
незліченні  давайте почитаємо, що у нас тут
печиво печиво хліб масло сир яйце
помідор рис сіль полуниця кавун
і банан, тому я даю вам одну хвилину і
поміщу їх у ці дві колонки
[Музика]
[Музика  ]
то ви готові,
давайте перевіримо, що ми маємо тут
злічене печиво, ми можемо порахувати печиво,
тому що це шматочок солодких яєць і,
звичайно, помідор, полуниця, диня і
банан, це зліченні іменники
і подивіться на другий стовпець червоне
незліченне масло сир рисова сіль  і
вода, до речі, гроші англійською мовою також
uncountable іменник, тому що ми
не говоримо багато грошей переміщаємо, ми говоримо багато
грошей, і ми дізнаємося це пізніше, так що
countable uncountable Я впевнений, що ви
знаєте і пам'ятаєте правила, як
форму множини від форми однини,
але давайте оновимо це цим завданням.
Ось деякі іменники в однині, і я б
хотів, щоб ви помістили його в цих п'яти рядках
ці п'ять рядків - це п'ять правил, як ми
утворюємо форму sing множини однини
за закінченням es  ending IES ending ves
неправильна форма доказу Laurel form, так що
добре, я даю вам дві хвилини, і ви
вставте їх у правильний рядок, тож переходьте
[Музика]
так що час закінчився
, ви готові, давайте перевіримо вашу роботу  добре,
давайте подивимося, і я зауважу,
зараз деякі правила так, це пустелі, ми просто
ставимо s і банани, також це дуже легкі
дні та відео так помідори, тут ми ставимо
es не просто як відео, і це
правило, якщо іменник закінчується на голосну  і
приголосний перед голосним ми плюс es,
як помідори та картопля, а якщо
іменник закінчується на о і голосний перед цим,
ми ставимо тільки s so персики та коробки
всі ці іменники, які із закінченнями, як
вона діє, вона ми ми, ми додаємо es, що закінчується okay
so  полуниця та вишня ці
іменники мають закінчення y, якщо у нас є закінчення y,
яке змінюється на це ягоди вишні
полуниці вишні добре, якщо у нас є
слово в однині, наприклад ніж, що закінчується на F
або полиця,
пам'ятайте, що ми змінюємо його на ves ножі
полиці ножі не вимовлятимуть ланцюг
і  неправильна форма як зуб це
однина зуби це множина особа це
однина
люди це множина і людина це
однина і чоловіки множина і пам'ятайте, що
риба буде однаковою формою в однині
і в множині  добре, отже, і це
слайд. Цей слайд розповідає про те, чому нам потрібно
це зробити, чи нам потрібно знати, яке слово є
лічильним, а яке незлічуваним, тому
що існує певне правило, як ми використовуємо деякі будь-які
та з іменниками, що підраховуються,
тому пам’ятайте, що ми використовуємо  артикль з
лічильною формою в однині прямо тут. У
мене є booger,
чи хочете ви яблуко, у неї є банан,
тому в однині ми використовуємо це або N і
використовуємо раніше, що починається з голосної,
добре, друге правило, ми використовуємо деякі з
незліченними і  зліченні іменники у
множині наприклад є трохи сиру
тут є трохи сиру тут трохи
сиру це незліченно і ми використовуємо деякі
так я купив банани банани його можна
підрахувати у множині і ми використовуємо деякі це
буде використовувати хтось ми не знаємо точно
як  багато бананів дека якусоку
сковорода готово. Я купив банани, добре, і
ми використовуємо будь-яке питальне та заперечне
речення, запам'ятайте деякі, які ми використовуємо в
стверджувальному реченні, а будь-які, які ми використовуємо в
питальному та заперечному реченні,
наприклад t  він будь-яке молоко чи є будь-яке
молоко молоко також незлічене, і
це питання, тому ми використовуємо будь-який
там немає цукру
немає цукру незлічений і
це негативне речення ми використовуємо будь-який
і останній приклад чи є якісь банани
чи є питання any bananas, яке ми використовуємо, будь-яке,
і він не має яблук. Також
це заперечне речення, і ми використовуємо будь-яке, тому
пам'ятайте, що ми використовуємо some в стверджувальному
реченні з незлічуваним і зліченим
у множині, а ми використовуємо будь-яке запитання та
негативне речення з  незліченні та
зліченні у множині занадто багато слів,
але ви пам'ятаєте, що ми
трохи потренуємось, а потім подивіться на це
зображення, тож давайте вправимо нашу граматику
граматику англійської англійської мови, тож ви повинні
помістити подивіться на зображення, ви можете побачити деякі
продукти, так, і ми  ми
повинні закінчити речення з
будь-яким звуком або n так речення номер один він
Бог добре
помідори що ми помістимо у вашому варіанті
ok Tomatoes їсть лічимі добре, так деякі
помідори так це  's стверджувальне речення
ми використовуємо деякі в стверджувальному реченні, як
це ok далі
he hasn't got he hasn't got it's
заперечне речення його заперечне речення,
але у нас є яйце в синьому або в
однині, тому ми використовуємо наш артикль
та де he hasn  Я не маю яйця, коли
Йохан Амайя Роуд знає, що це добре номер
три номер три у
нього немає ммм яблука яблука, які можна
підрахувати у множині, ми використовуємо будь-яке добро, зараз у
нього є хм, полуниця полуниця,
це можна порахувати у множині, коли ви маєте
наступне  t got mmm
brett-brett є незліченним, і ми використовуємо
його заперечне речення any okay hasn't got
any bread номер шість
he's got mmm milk it's ствердне
речення ми використовуємо some he's got some milk
і останнє це заперечне речення ми
використовуємо ah але ми  мати в однині he hasn't
got a burger oh no honey Maya boot he
hasn't got a burger ладно, ходімо
далі у нас є ще вправа подивіться
на цей холодильник подивіться, що у нас тут, у
цьому холодильнику, нам потрібно тут, щоб завершити
речення  про професіонала  канали всередині цього
холодильника з цими не залізними, а
деякі з ними, тож у нас є ця серія,
є причини, чому їх немає, і деякі
будь-які, щоб заповнити, тому X – це речення номер
один, дозвольте мені показати вам як приклад, що його
немає  'не будь-якої води з дном, ми
не бачимо води в холодильнику,
тому це буде негативне речення,
тому ми використовуємо будь-яку так, але у нас також є
цей варіант немає води
немає води в холодильнику добре, давайте подивимося ще раз
у цьому холодильнику у нас є апельсиновий сік, це
буде ствердне речення,
еквівалент Вірджинії на кам'яному Будді, який
варіант у вас ми будемо мати тут
є трохи апельсинового соку, якому 12 років,
у ствердному реченні ми використовуємо
трохи, а є
трохи соку  добре, піца номер три так, у
нас є велика піца, і ми кладемо
туди велику піцу, хочемо додати
мамі,
ми перейшли через девіз, тому ми
використовуємо велику піцу.
є
помідори так що ми  заповніть є деякі
Помідори є деякі Помідори добре
номер п'ять у нас є хліб чи є у вас
хліб там не думаю, тому я не думаю, щоб у
нас немає хліба, тому це буде
негативне речення добре заперечне речення, яке
ми використовуємо, немає  будь-який хліб о,
немає хліба, немає хліба,
немає хліба, немає
хліба, іди далі, номер шість, а як
щодо сиру, чи можна побачити чит, чи
можна побачити сир, так, у нас є сир,
тому це буде ствердне речення, і
є трохи  сир там добре номер
сім чи є у нас яблука у нас є яблуко в
однині в однині так що буде
тут є яблуко на ібаці
яблуко і останнє як щодо
полуниці полуниці ні я не
бачу полуниці так буде  заперечне
речення вони не будь-яка
полуниця не будь-яка полуниця або немає
полуниці добре добре
ще кілька граматичних правил про злічене
незлічене і про те, як ми використовуємо багато багато багато
і багато з цими іменниками добре пам'ятайте, що ми
використовуємо багато з зліченими іменниками  здебільшого в
питанні в і в заперечному реченні,
наприклад, у вас є
яйця. У мене не так багато яєць, ми використовуємо багато
з незліченною кількістю іменників у запитанні та
негативному реченні, наприклад, у мене немає
багато лимонаду, як у вас багато
води, і це дуже  легко, тому що багато
ми можемо використовувати як у злічених, так і в
незліченних, і в усіх видах
речення, як-от ствердне запитання та
заперечення.
Наступна
частина Я буду володіти Я обіцяв вам показати,
як ми можемо порахувати
незліченну кількість речей, ми можемо порахувати їх
за допомогою цієї чашки або банки, або ці слова
називаються позитивними, тому пляшка може мультфільм
чашка, шматочок скла і пакет, давайте покладемо
в потрібне місце  чашка чаю не
чай, але чашка чаю ми можемо порахувати
склянку молока ми можемо порахувати шматочок піци
банка газованої води відпочинок на бунці банка
газованої води коробка апельсинового соку пакет
цукру, який ми можемо порахувати, і пляшка  воду
ми можемо рахувати добре так і добре і зараз  як
завжди наприкінці це наше домашнє
завдання домашнє завдання описати ці картини,
використовуючи декілька будь-яких багато багато-багато
і резерв це натюрморт
Катарини нижче ядра наших українських
художників, а це ви вже
знаєте Джозіа Арчібальда та  його портрет,
так опишіть ці фотографії, використовуючи
знання, які ми сьогодні навчилися, і
залишайтеся вдома, будьте здорові та щасливі,
дякую і до побачення
[Музика]
вам